[Music]
here are the 10 biggest dragons from the
game of thrones universe which means
most of these dragons will be from the
house of the dragon of the series aka
the dance of the dragons so let's get to
it at number 10 we have melees the red
queen is on the number 10 spot as we can
see her in the fifth episode of her
flying alongside sea smoke on the way to
king's landing melees is a red dragon
who has a similar body type to drogon
and can be seen being the same size as
drogon from the last season of game of
thrones but since the timeline of house
of the dragon will fast forward several
years in the upcoming episodes she will
no doubtly be bigger
at number 9 we have caraxes the
bloodworm written by daemon targaryen is
a deformed dragon who has a body type
that is more serpent-like than all the
others it is long and slithery with
massive front wings and legs that have
secondary wings attached to them it is a
volatile and hot tempered dragon with a
monstrous head that has two large horns
that are very prominent in the first
episode it is seen as a large dragon the
size of drogon and by the time of the
fourth and fifth episode it is clearly
larger
number 8 dream fire yet to be seen in a
live action series but was very well
explained in the books no doubt we are
going to see her in house of the dragon
dream fire was a slender female dragon
with a skin that is almost pale blue
with silver patterns her crest was
silver and her wings are blue in color
dreamfire had grown large enough by 35
ac after aegon's conquest for reina
targaryen to saddle her so by the time
of dance of the dragons 100 years later
she would have probably been a very
large dragon
number 7 sheep stealer this dragon egg
hatched when king jahirus the first
targaryen was still young therefore
would have been prior to 34 ac a sheep
sailor made its lair in the caverns of
the dragon man a volcano in dragonstone
its coloring was an ugly mud brown he
was not aggressive towards humans unless
provoked he was said to be a skinny
dragon even if he was almost a century
old therefore he might be large but
[ __ ] in growth probably like
caraxies
number six silver wing according to
legend silverwing hatched from a
dragon's egg that has been placed in the
cradle of alisand targaryen by her
sister rayna in 36ac so when the dance
of the dragons happened she was already
only a few years shy of a century
therefore she would have been very old
powerful and of huge size silverwing has
been described as a silvery dragon she
was considered relatively docile and
friendly to strangers and was a
companion to vermithor
number five miraxis although she was one
of the original three dragons of aegon
the conqueror miraxis was killed by a
darnish scorpion ball 10 years after the
conquest therefore even though she was
bigger and older than vega when she was
alive by the time of the dance of the
dragons vegar and other dragons had
already grew older than she ever was and
probably were way bigger nevertheless
she was still a beast capable of
swallowing a horse hole
number four vermathor vermathor was a
bronze dragon with great tan wings
he was already a large dragon in 48 ac
only valerian and vega were larger by
the time of the dance of the dragons
brahmatha was almost 100 years old and
was a fearsome animal he was accustomed
to people already having had one rider
before in the reign of aegon ii
targaryen so he was tolerant of people
and their presence and accepting of new
riders he often called with silverwing
and was her companion
number 3 vegar the novels do not specify
the color or shape of vegas scales horns
wings or spinal crests she was described
by george rr martin as being golden with
greenish blue accents and striking green
eyes in an interview vega was a hardened
survivor of a hundred fights at a time
of the dance of the dragons and had
almost grown to the size of balerion and
was the oldest and largest dragon
investors at that time her roar was so
loud that it could rock storm's end to
its core
number two the cannibal the cannibal is
said to be the eldest and the biggest of
the three wild dragons in dragonstone
making him older than sheep stealer and
even bigger some dragonstone locals said
that the cannibal resided on the island
way before the targaryens came in 114 bc
if the cannibals sprang from a distinct
bloodline of dragons that might explain
why it was so hostile to other targaryen
dragons so at the least he would have
been a bit smaller than valerion or even
bigger in the highest estimate or maybe
of the same size
and number one the biggest valerian the
black dread valerian had black scales
and wings his fire was black with
crimson swirls here and there when he
was at his most powerful his flames
could melt steel and stone and fuse sand
into glass since aegon's conquest
valerian had been the biggest of all
targaryen dragons when he flew overhead
his wingspan was so wide that his shadow
could cover entire villages his jaws
were huge enough to devour an rock or a
hairy mammoth hole
so yeah he is that big the biggest
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video on the biggest dragons from game
of thrones
so do hit that like button for support
and subscribe as well but most of all
smash that bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam